My name is Abigail Whitelow and I am based in London.
For the Dezeen and Samsung Out of the Box Competition…
...I have designed a modular display and storage system called Tessellate.
Tessellate comprises a series of identical modules...
...made from recycled cardboard...
...which can be arranged in many different ways.
This product is designed to be made from a large Eco-Packaging box...
...such as for Samsung’s The Frame television which can produce four modules.
You can arrange them in many ways to create shelving for different rooms.
And it can easily be adapted, giving endless possibilities...
...to a cardboard box that would usually be discarded.